MEMBER MAZE NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANT AT
ARMS OF REPAIR THE CHAMBER
BRINGING APPS TO MEMBERS AND
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
HI WE ARE CURRY. RAMBOVA PARA
QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN HELLO
BLOOM ONE OR MORE OF A-
BONTERRA. MERCK COLLARBONE
CORREO SAVANT THIS CHOW JUNE TO
CHOI JULIE COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DAILY DAVIES FLORA PHONE
RAZER FREEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CHRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIBSON GONZALEZ
GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN- WHEN
JONES SAWYER ALL RIGHTS M.
LONGER KYLIE LACKEY LEE LEVIN
LOW MAIN SHINE MAP THIS MAIS
MCCARTY MEDINA ALAN MOORE SU
CHI MISSOURIAN QUINN O'DONNELL.
EDISON BETWEEN NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA RAMEAU'S RAY. LOOSE
REEBOKS ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SOLACE SANTIAGO SAY
ARTURO SMITH STONE TEAM
VALIDATORS WE APPROVED WHAT
WILL PRO WALDRON BOARD WICKS
WORD. MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE
ASKED OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
ALMIGHTY GOD. IN YOUR INFINITE
MERCY AND UNDERSTANDING BE
PATIENT WITH US. WITH OUR
MISTAKES AND OUR FALTERING
EFFORTS SAVE US FROM BEING
DISCOURAGED AND DISILLUSIONED
BY FAILURE. SAVE US FROM
UNCONTROLLED PRIDE IN OUR
SUCCESSES. GIVE US EACH DAY TO
DO OUR BEST FOR THE WORLD AND
FOR OURSELVES. HELP US TO LOOK
FOR AND SEE THE BEST IN EACH
INDIVIDUAL AND EACH ENDEAVOR.
HELP US TO BE POSITIVE AND
HAPPY WITH YOU AND WITH OUR
SOULS I MEAN. THANK YOU BOB YES
SIR YES SIR GUESS VISITORS
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN US
SIMPLY NUMBER GABRIEL AS HE
LEAVES US IN THE PLEDGE MR
GABRIEL COLLINS PLEASE JOIN ME
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES OR-
PETER. SANDERS ASIAN. S. S. OR-
THANK YOU MAYBE SEE A- REALLY
THE PREVIOUS DAY JOURNAL.
LITERATURE RESEARCH A FRIDAY
TWO TWENTY ONE IS SEEN THE
BETTER NOT EMB AUDIBLE ABOUT
HANNAH BECAUSE TEM OF THE
SIMPLY BECAUSE I CHIEF SUPER DE
FOR BOWMAN READING THE ROLE
CALLED MEMBER BONTA MOVED CORN
CALL THE SIM MOTION TIME THE
ASSISTANT SPEAKER TEM TO SO AT
ARMS CLOSED DOOR ARE BRINGING
THE TO MEMBER. AT NINE AM AT
NINE ELEVEN AM TO SPEAK HIM
ABOUT AND CLEAR THIS PRESS THE
WAS COMPLETED THE FOLLOWING
ANSWER TO AND RECORDS REGULAR
BARRICADE HAND BEEN IT FOR
HELLO HORRIBLE BOMBS BURKE
COLDER CAREER OF ONTO CHILD
SHOOT SURE MS IS SMOOTH. THIS
VALID THERE IS. AT THE RATE OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
JUST WITH PRESIDENT TEMPERATURE
THERE ARE NOT INTRODUCTION A
REFERENCE BILLS BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
DEEMED RED AND A MAN STEAM AT
DA. MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE C. AND THERE ARE NINE TO
MOVE INTO MOTION AND OF THE
ABSENCE FOR THE DAY. FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TASHA BOERNER HORVATH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORETTA
GONZALES AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHRISTOPHER WARD. FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES
GALLAGHER. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARIE WALDRON.
FOR MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. JIM FRAZIER. MS RAY S.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PROCEDURAL MOTION MEMBERS. MS
RAISE YOUR RECOGNIZES THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO
ALLOW SIMPLY MEMBER COULEE DAM
AGAINST AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLIES GUEST WILL BE IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBERS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SO I SHOULD BE THE
ORDER. MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW SIMPLY MEMBERS AT
THE WATER GARCIA GIBSON AND BY
OTHER ARTISTS TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH A
B. THE ORDER. AND I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA. THE
FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENTS TO
ALLOW THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
MEET FOR AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON SCHOOL RE OPENING.
AND EARLY ACCESS BUDGET CLEANUP
TOMORROW MARCH SECOND AT NINE
AM IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE
HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO DIRECT
YOUR ATTENTION. TO MY DESK IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER I'M
GOING TO RECOGNIZE MR COOLEY.
WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
PRESENTATION TO MAKE. ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. CORRECTION MR
KOHLI WILL BE IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER. AND HOPEFULLY THE
ASSEMBLY TV BOOTH THIS
FOLLOWING THE ACTION HERE MR
COOLEY. YOUR RECOGNIZED IN THE
RED CHAMBER. MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO HONOR
RICK METALS ON THE OCCASION OF
HIS RETIREMENT AS TELEVISION
PRODUCER DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. AND
HE HAS SERVED IN THIS POSITION
FOR THIRTY YEARS. RICK WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN HAWAII WHERE HE
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WENT ON TO
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY OF HAWAII
AT MANOA. EARNING A BACHELOR OF
ARTS DEGREE IN COMMUNICATIONS.
HE LOST HIS MEDIA CAREER AS A
PRODUCER AND DIRECTOR FOR LIVE
NEWS. LIVE NEWS SPORTS
ENTERTAINMENT. WITH KGMB TV. TV
ON THE HAWAIIAN ISLANDS. BUT IN
NINETEEN NINETY HIS WIFE LAUREN
HIS SON JACOB MOVED TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WHERE MR MATTIS
BECAME BEGAN DIRECTING SEVERAL-
LIVE NEWS AND SPORTS FOR AREA
STATIONS FOR SEVERAL KOVR KCRA
AND. KBI ETV. WHILE WORKING TO
START. THE OF THE ACTION FOR
THE STANDPOINT OF GRADES. THANK
YOU FOR THE NEWS OF UNINSPIRING.
AND IT WAS DRAWN TO THE
POSITION OF TELEVISION PRODUCER
AND DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY. SO IN FEBRUARY
OF NINETEEN NINETY ONE HE
BECAME THE FIRST AND ONLY.
PERSON TO HOLD THE POSITION FOR
THE NEXT THIRTY YEARS. AS A
SIDE NOTE I CAN SAY THAT HIS
INTERVIEW PROCESS TOOK SIX
HOURS. RAZOR WILLIE BROWN. AND
A FORMER NEWSCASTER MEMBER OF
THIS HOUSE STANDS STATE. OF IT
IS THROUGH A DECADE RICK FACED
BIG CHALLENGES. AS A RESULT OF
BEING DIAGNOSED WITH MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS. AND THERE IS A
SERVER THAT WAS NINETY SIX IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT HE LOST
HIS WIFE OF WHO PASSED AWAY
PREDECEASED HIM. SO THEN HE
ADDED JUST BUCKLE DOWN AND
ROLLED HIMSELF TO BEING A GOOD
DAD TO HIS SON. AND IT MADE IT
HIS BUSINESS BECAUSE MUCH TIME
AS POSSIBLE INVENTIONS WITH HIS
SON JACOB. IN THE SPRING OF TWO
THOUSAND ONE. REGRET IS
CONNECTED WITH AN OLD HIGH
SCHOOL FRIEND RICKY HARRIS AND
FINALLY HAD MUCH IN COMMON.
THEY MARRIED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO AND MICKEY. IS BACK IN
HAWAII WHERE HE WILL SOON
RELOCATE AND HERE SHE IS HERE
IN SPIRIT AND OF THE RES THE
LADIES WE SEE ON HIM OUR GIFT
FROM MICKEY. FOR ME ONE MOMENT.
BUT HE DID ALL OF THIS WILL
STILL MASTERFULLY PERFORMING
HIS DUTIES FOR THE ASSEMBLY
DOCTRINE THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE HE'S BEEN
DISTINGUISHED BY CUSTOMER
PROFESSIONALISM UNSTINTING
DEDICATION AND VAST LEGISLATIVE
COMMUNICATION WITH EXPERIENCE
HE HAS BEEN A UNIQUE.
IRREPLACEABLE TO THIS POINT IN
TIME INVALUABLE ASSET TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
TAKING US IN THE ERA OF GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND USING MEDIA TO
COMMUNICATE THE WORKER
DEMOCRACY. AND IT IS THIS
REASON WE'RE OUR RECORD FOR HIS
MANY EXCEPTIONAL. AND
OUTSTANDING CHARACTER AND WISH
YOU HAVE AN- AND WELL DESERVED.
AND RICK. THIS RUSSELL THAT
COMES TO FROM OUR SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON. OUR SPEAKER PRO
TEM KEVIN BOLAND AND MYSELF AS
WELL SHARE AND AGAIN IT'S JUST
A GREAT HONOR TO. RECOGNIZE YOU
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THIS GREAT FINE
INSTITUTION RIGHT CAN.
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE MEMBERS. MEMBERS
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND THEY'LL NOISE
LEVEL IN THE CHAMBER. EVEREST
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER MEDINA AND THE WELL OF
THE ASSEMBLY THIS IS ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AC ARE. THIRTY CORKERY
ASSUMING CURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA
RELATIVE TO COVERT NINETEEN
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS MISTER
MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT ACR THIRTY. A
RESOLUTION TO RECOGNIZE THE
FIRST MONDAY OF MARCH AS COLD
NINETEEN MEMORIAL DAY. IT HAS
BEEN NEARLY A YEAR SINCE THE
FIRST DAY AT HOME ORDERS WENT
INTO PLACE. AND THE WORLD AS WE
KNEW IT DRASTICALLY CHANGED.
FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS THE WORLD
HAS CHANGED FOREVER. IN ONE
YEAR MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
TO COVE IN NINETEEN. MORE THAN
THE NUMBER OF US SOLDIERS LOST
IN WORLD WAR ONE AND WORLD WAR
TWO COMBINE. AND WE HAVE LOST
NEARLY FIFTY THOUSAND LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE. INCLUDING MY
OWN FATHER IN LAW. EACH LIFE
LOST IN THIS PANDEMIC. LEAVES A
HOLE IN THE HEART OF THOSE LEFT
BEHIND. THE FIRST STEP TO
HEALING IS RECOGNIZING THIS
ENORMOUS LOSS IN THE WAY THAT
CENTERS THE NEEDS OF THOSE MOST
IMPACTED. A KNOWLEDGE IS THE
TREMENDOUS IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND IS COMMENSRATE
TO THE SCALE OF THE PART OF THE
PROBLEM. A PUBLIC MEMORIAL DAY
CREATES A SPACE FOR US TO
REMEMBER AND GRIEVE AS A
COMMUNITY. IT ALSO PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT AND
LEARN FROM THIS EXPERIENCE TO
INSURE THAT WE ARE PREPARED TO
COMBAT FUTURE PANDEMICS. THIS
RESOLUTION IS A FIRST STEP
TOWARDS RECOGNITION OF THE
COLLECTIVE LOSS EXPERIENCE DUE
TO THIS PANDEMIC IN THE LONG
TERM IMPACT IT WILL HAVE. ON
CALIFORNIA AND OUR NATION'S. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS DIVE CALIFORNIA JOINT
STATES AND CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BY MAKING TODAY THE
FIRST MONDAY OF MARCH COLD AT
NINETEEN MEMORIAL DAY. THANK
YOU MISTER MEDINA. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISTER MEDINA WHICH YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS YES. MR MEDINA'S
REQUESTING CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. MEMBERS THE CLARK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON A C. R. THIRTY
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION. LOCAL CLOSER
ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
HR TWENTY FOUR BY MS CORREO THE
CLERK READ HOUSE RESOLUTION
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CORREO RELATIVE TO SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
AWARENESS MONTH MYSTERY- YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
RECOGNIZE MARCH A SUDDEN SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
AWARENESS MONTH A TRAGIC
CATEGORY OF DEATH. IN CHILDREN
THAT OCCURS WHEN A DEATH
REMAINS UNEXPLAINED AFTER A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION AND
AUTOPSY. CAN I GET THEM QUITE
ON THE MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISS KOREA. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER. THE CAUSE OF
DEATH CLAIMS THE LIVES OF ANNEX
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
THE UNITED STATES AND HAVE
CLAIMED NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
TWO LIVES IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN MOST OFTEN A
SEEMINGLY HEALTHY CHILD GOES TO
pWITH THE MIRACLES OF MODERN
MEDICINE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
CAUSED THE SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED
DEATH. IN A IN A IN CHILDHOOD.
HOW TO PREDICTED OR HOW TO
PREVENT IT. BECAUSE MANY
DEVELOPING NATIONS LACK AWAY TO
RECORD AND INVESTIGATE SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION DOES DOES
HAVE A METHOD TO TELL HOW
WIDESPREAD. THE PROBLEM MAY BE
AROUND THE GLOBE CORRECTION
THEY ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A
METHOD. SO WHAT CAN WE DO TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES AND WORK
TOWARD THE DAY WHEN NO ONE
SUFFERS THE LOSS OF A CHILD IN
SUCH AN UNEXPECTED AND TERRIBLE
WAY. FUNDS FOR RESEARCHWILL
FURTHER OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS CAUSE OF DEATH AND ALLOW
US TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
MEDICAL EXAMINERS PEDIATRICIANS
AND CORNERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ACCURATELY TRACKED. AND HAVE
DATA FOR EVERY CASE OF SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
NO MATTER WHERE IT HAPPENS.
TOMORROW WE WILL KNOW MORE THAN
WHAT WE DO TODAY BUT TODAY IS
AN IMPERATIVE THAT EVERY FAMILY
THAT SUFFERS FROM THIS TRAGIC
LOSS THAT SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
A NETWORK OF COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
AND COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL HEALTH
REASSURANCE TO HELP THEM IN
THEIR TIME OF BEREAVEMENT AND
THROUGH THIS GRIEVING PROCESS.
THERE IS THE SCRIPTURE ABOUT
FINDING HOPE IN A KIND OF
MORNING THAT READS I THINK OF
YOU YOU ARE MY HELP I SING IN
THE SHADOW OF YOUR WINGS. EVERY
SOUL LOST TO SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED
DEATH IN CHILDHOOD IS AN ANGELCALLING US. CALLING UPON US TO
LIFT AND RAISE THE
CONSCIOUSNESS OF THIS ISSUE
THAT AFFECTS FAR TOO MANY
FAMILIES. THE LOS ANGELES
DODGERS ORGANIZATION HAS WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
FOUNDATION TO RAISE AWARENESS
OF THIS ISSUE OF GREAT PERSONAL
SIGNIFICANCE TO THE FAMILY OF
DOCTOR GREAT. SANDY KOUFAX AND
I THANK THEM FOR BRINGING THIS
TO MY ATTENTION I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON HR TWENTY FOREIGN
RECOGNIZE MARCH A SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
AWARENESS MONTH AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE ROLE
TO BE OPEN. FOR CO AUTHORS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MYSTERY-
OF MR VOLPE. YOUR RECKONER.
MANANA LEGISLATIVE SISTERS THE
BROTHERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR TWENTY FOUR FROM BITTER
EXPERIENCE I SPENT THIRTY NINE
YEARS IN THE INSURANCE BUSINESS
I'VE DONE THOUSANDS. OF DEATH
CLAIMS. JOINS I MUST TELL YOU
THAT THEY'RE THE WORST DEATH OF
FAMILY CAN EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE THAT LOST THEIR
CHILD ALWAYS THINK WHAT COULD I
HAVE DONE. COULD I HAVE. BEEN
IN THE CRIB WITH THEM WHAT.
POSSIBLE THINGS COULD HAVE
PREVENTED IT AND IT'S SO
HEARTBREAKING SO THOSE FOUR
CLAIMS THAT I DID BASICALLY
BROKE MY HEART. SO HR TWENTY
FOUR. GOOD ON YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE AUTHOR. A MAN.
THANK YOU MR RAFAEL MISSED COOL
YOU ARE IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES I'M VERY
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS JUST WANT REMARK ON THE
TRAY THAT THIS FOR. ACTUALLY
HAD THE YEAR OF FOUR FIVE YEARS
AGO- AND IT'S NOT JUST INFANTS
IT INCLUDES YOU PEOPLE- IN MY
AS SOON DISTRICT THERE WAS
YOUNG MAN IN HIGH SCHOOL NIKO A
TALENTED MUSICIAN BUSY IN HIS
COMMUNITY JUST A GREAT GREAT
SON WHO- CAME HOME ONE NIGHT
AND WENT TO BED. AND NEVER WOKE
UP. AND ALL OF THE MISS. AND
HORROR. AND CONFUSION. THAT IS
UNEXPLAINED THEY CANNOT
UNDERSTAND HERO THERE ARE
INDICATIONS OF ANY MISCONDUCT
ON THE INDIVIDUAL'S PARK IT'S
JUST INCREDIBLY TRAGIC AND THE
UNEXPLAINED PART IS AS MUCH A
**** FOR ANYTHING ELSE BECAUSE
NO ONE CAN KIND OF MAKE SENSE
OF THE SORT OF THING. A VIBRANT
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD AS I SAY
NICOLE WAS A YOUNG MAN MIGHT SO
I DEFINITELY I'M SO GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON IT IT IS OF.
IT IS MYSTIFYING UNEXPLAINED
BUT HEARTBREAKINGLY. COMMON SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MR KOHLI. I SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. MS CORREO IS ASKING
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION. THE CARD CLUB IN
THE ROLE. FOR COOPER'S TO
AUTHORS AND HR TWENTY FOUR.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WELL
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT TO THE HOUSE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. AT THIS TIME.
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
WE ARE AT A GERMAN TO MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS READ A
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
INTERMENT IN MEMORY. MR EDUARDO
GARCIA YOUR RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN THE
SESSION. IN THE MEMORY OF US
OUTSIDE I HATED. HE LEADER AND
ACTIVIST FOR FARM WORKERS BUT
THE THOUGHT OF PASSED AWAY AT
THE AGE OF FIFTY EIGHT. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE RAFA THEIR
CHILDREN ABOUT THE SURGEON YOUR
CASSANDRA AND JACQUELINE I GAVE
IT. HIS BROTHER WITH DOUBLE AND
SISTER HEMMA I EVEN. BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX TO A FAMILY
OF EIGHT BROTHERS AND SISTERS
BUT THE THOUGHT CAME TO THE US
FROM ONE O'CLOCK OR- AS A
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS. BUT THE
FEDERATED BEGAN ITS PATH OF
ACTIVISM. AT OUR LOCAL PATELLA
GROVER CITRUS STRETCH. IN THE
LATE NINETEEN SEVENTIES HE
BECAME A CREW REPRESENTATIVE
AND A MEMBER OF THE UNITED FOOD
WORKER NEGOTIATION COMMITTEE.
KNOWN FOR HIS PASSION TO SERVE
OTHERS BY THE THOUGHT WAS
ELECTED AS A DOWN TO REPRESENT
HIS COWORKERS AT MANY UNITED
FOOD WORKER CONSTITUTIONAL
CONVENTIONS. THERE HE JOINED
COUNTLESS MARCHES RALLIES
BOYCOTTS LEGISLATIVE AND
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS NO STRANGER
TO THIS BILL. I WANTED TO REACH
MORE FARMERS ACROSS THE STATE
BY THE SIDE LEFT HIS POSITION
TO WORK AT THE UFW ORGANIZER IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. AS A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZER FIGHTING
FOR FARMWORKERS HE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO FACE FEAR
AND INTIMIDATION TACTICS EVERY
SINGLE DAY. DURING THE CENTRAL
COAST ROBBERY ORGANIZING DRIVE
IN WATSONVILLE BUT THE SITE WAS
FINALLY ATTACKED. BUT THAT
DIDN'T STOP HIM. HE RESPONDED
THE NEXT DAY BY KNOCKING ON
DOORS AND MEETING WITH LOCAL
FARM WORKERS TO CONTINUE ON THE
EFFORT OF ORGANIZING THEM FOR
BETTER WORK CONDITIONS. IT WAS
BECAUSE BY THE SIDE CARRIED
WITH HIM A COMMITMENT TO
NONVIOLENCE AND A PEACEFUL
PROTEST. AND VALERIE. FOR THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS HE WORKED AT
THE UNIONIZED HM AS AGRICULTURE
CORPORATION IN COACHELLA AS AN
ELECTED FARMWORKER LEADER.
DURING HIS TENURE HE HELPED
SECURE THE ROBERT F. KENNEDY
MEDICAL PLAN COVERAGE FOR ALL
H. M. S. WORKERS ENSURING FARM
WORKERS RECEIVE ADEQUATE
HEALTHCARE. THE MOTHER THOUGHT
IT WAS NOT FIGHTING FOR
FARMWORKERS HE SANG IN THE
CHOIR AND PLAYED THE GUITAR.
AND A LOCAL CATHOLIC PARISH AND
IN THE COMMUNITY OF BLIGHT. TO
HONOR THOSE KILLED DURING
FORMER STRIKES ON THE FINAL DAY
OF YOUR W. CONVENTIONS BUT THE
THOUGHT ALWAYS HELP ORGANIZE A
RELIGIOUS SERVICE ON THEIR
BEHALF. HE IS A MAN OF STRONG
FAITH. BUT THE SIDE HAD HIS
DREAM REALIZED WHEN HE WAS
ORDAINED AS A DEACON IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY. LET US
CELEBRATE MOTHER THOUGHT I GIVE
HIS LIFE WORK AND LEGACY. AND
IF I MAY JUST- DRESS THE WIFE.
BRONSON IS CHILDREN WERE
WATCHING TODAY. MY MOM SAYS
NINE OUT OF ONE OF THE SIDE OF
MY STUNTED. THROUGH COMPROMISSO
ULTIMA THEY'VE GONE FULL CIRCLE
FOR ME SELECT ONLY THAT. YOU
MUST ANOTHER LOVE AFFAIR. GUESS
HE APPLICABLE IF YOU'RE GOING
TO SORT OF GET THE NEON. CLOSE
BUT- THE IT'LL PULL IT ALSO TO
SEE WANT TO. THE STRING OF
THEIR MOST BETTER GONNA THAT
EMMA. THAT IS TO TURN HIS
MEMORY TODAY CALLING ARE YOU
TODAY THIS I GAVE IT- UNITED
FORMER FIRED IN A GREAT
FATHER'S. AND MAN OF GOD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GARCIA.
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THERE IN THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE **** BODY
TO- JOIN ME IN CHURNING IN
MEMORY. OF RUBBER NORMA J.
FISHER. RIVER FISH WAS BORN ON
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH NINETEEN
FORTY TWO AND MARRIED TO THE
LATE. DR W. JEROME FISHER MY
DEEPEST SYMPATHY GOES OUT TO
HER CHILDREN PASTOR SHELTON.
EVETTE JAMISON DANA KIT AND MY
DEAR FRIEND FRATERNITY BROTHER.
PASTOR SENIOR PASTOR MICHAEL
FISHER OF THE GREATER ZION
CHURCH IN THE CITY OF COMPTON.
WHERE HER ROOM WHERE THE MOTHER
OF NORMA FISHER WAS ALSO SERVED
AS A MEMBER FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS MEMBERS YOU MAY
REMEMBER GREAT DESIGN GREAT
DESIGN SONG AT THE GOVERNOR'S
UP INAUGURATION HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. AND DURING THAT TIME.
EVERY NORMA FISHER WAS IN
ATTENDANCE SHE WAS A WOMAN OF
FAITH WHO LEAD WITH PURPOSE
EMPATHY. AND GRACE. RIVER NORMA
FISHER GRADUATED WITH HER
NURSING DEGREE IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE FROM THE SAINT JOHN
CHURCH OF NURSING IN MISSOURI.
BUT AS A FIRM BELIEVER OF
EDUCATION HER LOVE FOR BOOKS
SHE REFUSED TO STOP. JUST AT
THE NURSING DEGREE IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR SHE ENROLLED INTO
THE CALVARY CHAPEL BIBLE
COLLEGE TO ENHANCE HER
KNOWLEDGE OF THE WORD OF GOD.
SHE WENT TO RECEIVE HER
HONORARY DOCTORATE DEGREE IN
DIVINITY BY THE BIBLE
UNIVERSITY. MINISTERING BESIDE
HER CHILDREN IN A FAMILY SHE
ALWAYS PUT GOD FIRST IN
EVERYTHING SHE DID YOU SEE GOD
WAS THE FOUNDATION OF WHO SHE
WAS. IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
SHE BECAME THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BAPTIST MINISTERS WIVES AND
WIDOWS OF LOS ANGELES AND MADE
IT HER PURPOSE TO MINISTER TO
WOMEN OF ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
LATER IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN REVAN FISHER ACCEPTED
HER CALLING TO PREACH THE
MINISTRY. AND RECENTLY BECAME
ORDAINED IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. MAY HER
PASSION AND DEVOTION TO SERVE
OTHERS WITH THE WORD OF GOD
LIVE IN THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
EVERYONE WHO KNEW HER AND WAS
TOUCHED BY THE WORK SHE DID
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF THE
LATE REVEREND NORMA J. FISHER.
DAVIS GIVES. THIS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMANS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER I
RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE THE
LIVES OF TWO LOCAL HEROES. OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
LOST TWO OF ITS FINEST THIS
MONTH RETIRED CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL SERGEANT
BENJAMIN A D. BEAN AND LA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPUTY PEDRO
P. RAMA. THER TO BE KNOWN FOR
HIS HUMOR DE TO HIS FAMILY AND
HIS STELLAR SERVICE RETIRED
FROM THE NEW HALL AREA
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL IN
FEB OF TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
BUT HE'S TIME. DID SUIT THE
SERGEANTS FOR. AND HE CONTINUED
HIS AND I AREA IN ANY WAY HE
COULD HE BUILT FOR VETS.
INCLUDE THE HOME AND IT WAS THE
HOME OF HIS OLDEST DAUGHTER
DESERT. HE DID FRIEND WITHIN
THE VETERAN. AND THE A HELP
HAND TO COW FAMILIES. QUICKLY
THEN BECAME KNOWN AS DEAL
BECAUSE THAT IS WHO WE WHAT. HE
WAS AT THE- TO EVERYONE. THE
SERGEANT WILL BE MISSED GREATLY
BY OUR COMMUNITY HIS WIFE TWO
DAUGHTERS AND SUB GRAND. SOME
IT UP ALL LOST DE PEDRO P. RAMO
WHO WAS HONORED LAST BY FIRST.
THAT SPAN MY- LINING BRIDGES
EXTENDING OVER THE I. FIVE AND
LOCAL STREETS WINDING
THROUGHOUT NEIGHBORHOODS OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY WAS
JOINED BY SOME OF THE YOUNGEST
MEMBERS OF THE LANCIA AND SANTA
CLARITA. AS DEPUTY ROMO SERVED
OUR COMMUNITY AS A SCHOOL
DEPUTY AS A SCHOOL DEPUTY AT
RIO NO CHERRY JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL AND BALENCIAGA HIGH
SCHOOL FOR MORE THAN A DECADE.
HE PROTECTED OUR STUDENTS HIS
PRESENCE ON. BEING ABLE IS
COMFORTABLE THE TEAM WHO
ENTERED THE SCHOOL GATES EVERY
MORNING DEPUTY ROMO IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE NATALIE AND HIS
THREE CHILDREN AND HE LEAVES
BEHIND. A MORNING OMMUNITY. IS
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I ASKED
THAT THIS BODY A GEORGIA MEMORY
OF SERGEANT BEN DID BEAN AND
DEPUTY PEDRO P. RAMO. THANK YOU
MICHELLE ANDERS MR LACKEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE.
TO A PAY MY RSPECTS A GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE WHO HAS BEEN
BEING. AND THE- WE BOTH
PROMOTED TO SERGEANT AT THE
SAME TIME I WENT TO THE START
BREEZE SERGEANTS ACADEMY BACK
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. AND
THE- WE'RE BOTH ASSIGNED TO THE
IOWA VALLEY AREA IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX. AND- I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I'M I'M VERY THANKFUL
FOR. BEING ABLE TO WORK WITH
HIM BECAUSE HE SHARED. SOME OF
THE SAME VALUES THAT- I BELIEVE
ARE VERY VERY CRITICAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND THAT IS
TREATING EVERYBODY FAIRLY. THE
OF AND OBJECTIVELY A TREATING
OTHERS LIKE YOU EXPECT TO BE
TREATED LIKE IF. THAT PERSON
YOU'RE OVER WAS A MEMBER OF
YOUR FAMILY. AND WE BOTH DEEPLY
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE WE WOULD
BRIEF THAT. BEFORE EVERY SHIFT
AND WE REMIND EVERYBODY OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THEIR JOB BECAUSE
I THINK. TOO OFTEN DOES A LAW
ENFORCEMENT FORGET THE
SENSITIVITY. THAT THEY
REPRESENT AND HOW EVERYBODY
MOST PEOPLE ARE FEARFUL. WHEN A
CAGE LOVE FORSMAN ESPECIALLY IF
THEY DON'T LOOK LIKE ME. SO BEN
WAS A BELIEVER IN THAT VERY
SAME PRINCIPLE EXEMPLIFIED IT
AND ENCOURAGED IT. AND HE ALSO
GREETED ME AT ONE OF MY MOST.
MORRIBLE MOMENTS I SCALED DOWN
THE SIDE OF THE UNIVERSAL HOTEL
IN A FUNDRAISING EVENT FOR THE
VETERANS AND I'M TELLING YOU IT
WAS THE SCARIEST THING I'VE
EVER DONE BECAUSE OF A FEAR OF
HEIGHTS. BUT I DID IT. BECAUSE
I BELIEVED IN AND VETERANS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY. I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THE BAN WAS AN EXAMPLE OF
THINKING OUTSIDE OF THEM SO.
AND EVEN AFTER RETIRING HE
COMMITTED HIMSELF TO THE
VETERANS COMMUNITY. I THOUGHT
THEY WERE FOR THE EXAMPLE HE
SET FOR ME AND FOR ALL THOSE
AROUND HIM. AND I'M- SORRY TO
SEE THAT THE HE'S PASSED ON.
BUT THAT I'M- HONORED TO STAND
AND ASK. THAT THIS BODY
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR LACKING THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES THE DESI PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS A SESSION
SCHEDULE. IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
MARCH SECOND CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY MARCH THIRD CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY MARCH THE
FOURTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE
AM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN OUR MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING HEARING OR
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
THIS RADIANCE MOVES IS VALID
THERE SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
MARCH THE FOURTH AT NINE AM IN
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.